SPEAKER: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here.
On behalf of [? Hola ?] LAX,
Google Talks At, and Latino
Heritage LA, I'd like
to welcome everyone
to our first Hispanic Heritage
Month event, where we're
going to have a panel
discussion, where we celebrate
the vibrancy of Latinidad or
the many different aspects that
make us Latino.
Today, we will hear firsthand
from three very talented
local Latina artists,
each one of them
providing their own
take on what it means
to be an artist in the US.
I will start with
Sandra in the middle.
Sandra Cornejo is a
first-generation Salvadoran
American artist born
in Houston, Texas.
Historical collective
memory of post-civil war
Salvadoran culture is
an important influence
and inspiration for her work.
She recently implemented a
portfolio preparation course
at Plaza de la Raza
for students aspiring
to continue their education
and profession in the arts.
Sandra received a BFA from
VCU, with a concentration
in painting and printmaking.
Recipient of the Ellen
Battell Stoeckel Fellowship,
she attended the Yale
Norfolk Summer Program.
Thanks for being here.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Thank you.
Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER: Then we have Yolanda
all the way to the left,
or to your right, was born
into a family whose artistic
heritage dates back to 1877.
Gonzalez's travels in different
countries, the bonds forged
with individuals
in those places,
and the resulting
transformative experiences
are reflected in her
art and her life.
She is known for her
strong, bold brush
strokes of color and
texture, intent on evoking
imagination and emotion.
She was an artist in
residence in Ginza, Japan,
followed by a similar
stint in Assisi, Italy.
Throughout the years, Gonzalez
has taught at various community
organizations.
You can see some of her
work on the gold line trains
as well as buses throughout LA
in a collaboration with AARP.
Yolanda studied at the Pasadena
Art Center College of Design
after winning a painting
competition that awarded her
a scholarship to the
prestigious school.
Thanks again.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
Thanks for having me.
SPEAKER: Of course.
And now we have Rosalie Lopez,
a Los Angeles-based artist
whose work involves combining
cultural iconography
with references of her
everyday surroundings.
At a young age, she
was heavily impacted
with the realities of loss,
addictions, and violence
within her immediate
family, which
continue to shape her
perspectives in society
and culture.
She primarily uses printmaking,
papel picado, installation,
and the altar offering
to relay experiences
of survival, loss, and pride.
Rosalie earned a
master of fine arts
in printmaking from Indiana
University and dual bachelor
of fine arts degrees
in graphic design
and printmaking from California
State University, Long Beach.
All three women have
had their artwork
exhibited in many museums
around the country
and internationally.
So let's give them
a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Welcome to
the Google Familia.
This is very exciting.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Happy to be here.
SPEAKER: Super-exciting
to do, you know,
Hispanic Heritage
Month, first event.
And we have you.
Yay.
So I'm super, super-excited
to not only have you here.
But also, your artwork.
If you haven't seen the
fabulous display of artwork
that we have here and the
collection in the boardwalk--
some people are like,
what is the boardwalk?
In front of the barista,
outside of Big Lebowski,
that is our boardwalk.
That's where we have six
different artists displayed.
And three of them
are right here.
So I'd love to know.
So there was probably
a thought process,
which artwork bring to Google?
Was that hard?
We have six, four, one.
Sandra, you
specifically chose one.
Yolanda, like six.
Rosalie chose four.
I'm very interested, like
the behind-the-scenes look
at why these pieces and what
the selection process was.
So just so everybody knows,
if we go to one slide,
this is Yolanda's work.
Yolanda, tell us about this.
Why did you choose these
very particular pieces
to have here with us today?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Well, I
wanted to exhibit something
contemporary, something that
was representational of my work
that was more recent that
had all of the texture
that I usually
use, the color that
is known for the Chicano art.
And I wanted to send
some of the works
that I'm most excited about--
SPEAKER: Oh, very nice.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: --which
are some still lifes
and some portraits.
And these are
portraits of people
that I know that are dear to me,
that represent strength, power,
positive energy, and love.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
And now that we're
in the subject,
I noticed that two
of the paintings
are called Diana something.
Who is this Diana person?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
Well, Diana Galicia
is a very dear friend of mine.
And her husband is an
incredible jewelry maestro.
So this is Diana's husband.
This is all of the
work that he creates.
And we've known each
other for about 25 years.
And she's just a
brilliant woman.
Brilliant, powerful woman.
SPEAKER: Great.
That's so nice.
Do they have this artwork
in their homes as well?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: They do.
They have some.
They have a house in Tulum.
And they've taken some
portraits that I've
created of them to their home.
SPEAKER: That's wonderful.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And then on the next page,
we have Rosalie's work.
Rosalie, you have four
different pieces here
with papel picado
and different things.
Tell us, why these
specific pieces?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Kind of going
off what Yolanda was saying,
I wanted to pick
work that exemplified
what I'm creating right now.
As a printmaker and
someone who combines
that with papel picado,
I wanted to choose
works that talk about
the ofrenda and offering
in a very contemporary way, in
untraditional somewhat ways.
So I have a papel picado
piece of an LA scene, a family
portrait that I combine
with LED lights and a couple
other ofrenda pieces that
are all papel picado.
So I felt like
together, they make
a grouping that really talks
about the things that I feel
embody the concepts
that I work with.
SPEAKER: That's great.
Thank you.
Yeah.
So you do these and
also tons of other?
Because you combine--
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I do
installation art.
Sometimes, it's just pure
printmaking mixed together
sometimes with papel picado.
So I really enjoy creating--
transforming spaces to
give people an experience.
So sometimes, that means
breaking out of the frame
and inhabiting a space.
SPEAKER: Nice.
Thank you.
That's great.
And now we're going
to see Sandra's work.
And Sandra's very specific.
You have this big, huge artwork.
SANDRA CORNEJO: I
chose one piece.
SPEAKER: One.
I'm very curious, why one?
SANDRA CORNEJO: One piece.
Well, it's a group of work
that I'm currently working on.
I tend to work in series.
So at the moment, I'm exploring
notions of childhood, memory,
nostalgia, like what drives
that nostalgic power.
And this image is--
is it something that's
been romanticized?
Something that's been skewed?
Like why?
Why does it have that power?
So I love kind of
asking these questions
as I'm making the work.
So as you see this piece,
it's representational,
yet has very abstract
elements to it.
So kind of like a push and pull,
like an inquiry of my past,
like where I come from.
So it's a very
tender, loving memory.
It's a bit like discombobulated
and may make sense.
And it might bring truth to
some of my viewers, I hope.
SPEAKER: No, I loved it.
All the work is beautiful.
And I thought it
was very powerful
that you just chose one.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Yeah.
SPEAKER: I need to know more.
[LAUGHS] So I like
to know also--
so you were talking about
themes and how right now,
you're working on this
theme of childhood.
What drives a theme?
Like For all three
of you, when you
work on a theme, what is
that driver or that influence
to go on that theme?
How do you choose the
theme that is next?
SANDRA CORNEJO:
Well, there tends
to be themes that I've been
working with for a really
long time, whether
it's commemorating
a figure, like in
a monolithic space,
like one figure in a space.
Like why?
Like telling a story.
Always very narrative-like.
So childhood, social
justice, where I'm from--
El Salvador.
Like, it's history.
So it's very historically-based.
And I'm always seeking
out a narrative.
And whatever that
narrative may be,
that's the image that surfaces.
SPEAKER: Great.
How does it work
for both of you?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
I think for myself,
it's something
that's very personal.
And I try to cover
narratives that
are what people are going
through along with myself.
And that reality and how that
reality is portrayed on canvas
in a beautiful manner.
SPEAKER: Thank you.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: In
my case, I feel
like I'm very much inspired by
my community, my neighborhood.
And in the beginning,
a lot of my work
was definitely influenced
by Dia de los Muertos altars
and how women would use
these altars as a platform
to discuss social
issues in the community
as a way to have a voice and
gathering assemblage work.
And so from that, and
using my own experiences,
I use it as a way to talk about
people who I want to praise
or I want to commemorate
and how we can take pride
in our communal
histories and stories
and display them as something
to be very proud about.
SPEAKER: Nice.
Do you feel that--
so of course, artwork
is your emotion.
There's a voice behind it.
Do you feel there's a voice or
an emotion that you tap into,
and when you do,
better work comes out?
What it is?
Some people are like, I need
to be depressed or [INAUDIBLE]..
I don't know.
I'm not an artist like
this, to this magnitude.
I do little things for
my children, but not--
or certainly like in school.
Tell me, how does that work
for you in that process?
SANDRA CORNEJO: No,
definitely, like for me
in my works, the struggle.
Like, a struggle, any struggle,
perseverance, overcoming,
beauty, like all of these
very strong elements
that just run through all of
my work is what drives it.
Like, absolutely.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I definitely feel
like in my case, the materials
that I use and the person
that I'm dedicating it to
are things that I harness.
And I want that energy
to transmute and infuse
into the artwork.
So I pull on a lot
of those emotions.
Most of the people I
use are people that I'm
connected to in some way.
So I have a
relationship with them.
And if I'm commemorating
a past memory
or igniting thoughts
from other viewers in it,
I want them to
cherish those things
and to have value so
that they don't forget.
SPEAKER: Nice.
OK.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I
think my inspiration
is people, the
relationships that we have,
and the emotions that they evoke
in my soul and in my heart.
So when there's
somebody that I'm
passionate about that I'm
creating a portrait of,
you definitely see
it on the canvas.
SPEAKER: Of course.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Absolutely.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
So it's that emotion that
we're discussing, right?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: So when
you're doing people--
I mean, it's people you're
passionate about or very
excited to evoke.
Is it just all pure
happiness, or do you
have like inner emotions
that are coming out
in this painting, too,
that you're trying to--
I mean, like there's
always subliminal messages.
Do you do that, too?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
I think there's
all kinds of emotions
that transpire
in the creative process.
And it's that relationship
between your canvas.
And since I've been
painting for 30 years,
it's a love relationship.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: And it's
this medium that feeds my soul.
And then, there's
this other person.
So it's a dialogue
between the three of us.
Between the creative
process the canvas, myself,
and the sitter, the
portrait I'm creating of.
And so definitely,
there's different emotions
that come out.
And it's lovely to
allow yourself to convey
that with the brushstrokes.
SPEAKER: Sure.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Definitely.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Tell me.
Tell me.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I was
just going to say,
it's like a form
of communicating.
Instead of using words,
you can say it best
with images and textures.
And as those things layer,
it creates the emotion
that you're not
quite able to put
into the same sort of wording.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: You hope
that people get that when
they see it, or it allows
them to see something
in a different
way, because that's
how you find your mode of
communication happening best.
SPEAKER: Sure.
So it's like for the next Google
Talk, we'll just have easels.
[LAUGHTER]
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Absolutely.
Great idea.
Let's do it.
SPEAKER: So I'm very proud to
be amongst all these Latinas,
right?
It's wonderful.
And I'm thinking,
how hard is it?
I mean, a Latina, a
woman, basically, you're
an entrepreneur.
How hard is it in the art world
to be a Latina and a woman
in a business that's--
there's a lot of men in it, too.
Tell me.
I want to know.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
There are obstacles.
I tend to not focus on them.
I just continue to forge
forward and to continue
to be focused on what I'm doing
in business and my creativity.
So there's Yolanda Gonzalez,
who is the artist, the creative.
And there is Yolanda
Gonzalez, the businessperson.
And that was taught to me by
my dad, Leopoldo Gonzalez,
who was a great businessman.
So I think if you can separate
yourself from the creative,
and then to the business
of this beautiful painting
that you're going to hand
over, that your soul is going
to hang in somebody's home.
I think it's important
to focus on that.
So there are
obstacles, but I think
like in any other line
of work, I just focus on
a clear, straight,
and narrow road.
And that's to my goal.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It's
the Latino backbone.
We have parents and family
who teach us how to work hard,
who show us what it's like to
have dedication into something.
And I feel like I definitely
pull from that, too.
My mom, single parent mom.
And what she did to
make things work.
And you use that,
transmute that into what
goals you want to accomplish.
And it comes through.
You could tell
people's drive, and you
could see it
because they learned
from people before them.
Not even in the same field
or a different thing,
but they see it being
applied, and then it
trickles down into your
own personality and the way
that you work.
SPEAKER: Sure.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I think that
there is definitely a struggle.
Being an artist is not easy.
I wanted Yolanda to
answer first because she's
got a lot more experience
than Sandra and I.
We're newer in
this sort of game.
So I feel like I learned
from women like her
that their strength
and their passageways,
them pioneering
these paths for us,
make it a different world for
us than it was, I think, even
in their timeframe.
So I acknowledge that.
I really feel like
they are people
that I like to look up
to and I learn from.
I'm a teacher, too.
So I feel like as an instructor,
as a teacher, sometimes
the students don't think like,
oh, where is the teacher at?
Oh, that's me.
I'm right here.
I appreciate her boldness
and her strength.
And I think that's
something that I really
admire about Yolanda.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Thank you.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It comes
through in her work.
And I feel like I'm
coming to my own in that.
I'm finding that
voice and I'm figuring
how that communicates
with my surroundings
and my neighborhood.
I feel like I can be a venue
for communicating these things.
How I am impacted
by them and how
other people see this
happening in our communities.
So we play an important
role in showing people
that it's not the same route
to understanding what's
happening in our culture
and our neighborhood.
And I feel thankful to be
a part of events like this
because it's not a voice
that's commonly heard.
It's not a voice where
we often get a platform
to be such a strong voice.
So I appreciate being
involved with it
and being involved with
artists like these.
SPEAKER: Of course.
Are you kidding?
You're always welcome.
Yeah.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I'd like to
say thank you for saying that.
I appreciate it.
And I've worked hard to keep
my reputation and my persona
kind of a certain way for you.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: The
aura comes through.
SPEAKER: I love it.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
I never had kids.
I never had kids, but I
felt when I would go places,
I always tell my friends,
we're representing.
We are representing.
We're responsible.
Wherever we are, we are
responsible to hold up
who we are and
our whole culture.
Whether we're the only
Chicana in the room
at a function in a very astute
place, we're representing.
SPEAKER: Of course.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
It doesn't matter
if you're in the restroom or
if you're in the dining room,
people watch.
And you have to represent
who your culture is.
SPEAKER: Absolutely.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Very-- yeah.
SANDRA CORNEJO: And Los
Angeles, just in general--
like I've moved around a
bit, and I've experienced
different art communities.
But having arrived
here three years ago,
I found an art community here
that was just very inviting,
very giving.
Like finding these strongholds,
like these beautiful, powerful
women, like Chicana art is--
that'll give you--
I'm Salvadoran, but I
met this amazing artist,
Margaret Garcia, when
I first moved here.
And she's like, honey.
We're all the same here.
Within like a week of
me having meeting her,
like she already had me kind of
like meeting different people
and into exhibitions.
And it's just like
everyone here is like down
to help each other out, which is
something that you don't really
find in a lot of places.
It's a lot of power here within
the art community and Chicanas,
Latinas in general.
SPEAKER: So are you
paying it forward?
You were saying, you
always have a voice.
People are always watching.
Do you mentor?
Tell us a little bit about that.
Like what do you do to--
so to give to the
next generation?
[INAUDIBLE] you teach?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Right
now, I love teaching.
I teach right now at two
Cal State Universities,
at Cal State, Long Beach,
and Cal State, Northridge
and also at Cerritos College.
So teaching art, I feel like
some of my biggest mentors
that I have, a lot of them were
professors and some of them
were working artists
outside of the institution.
I try to think about how I can
bring that communal experience
and working with artists
outside of the institution
and think about how you can
bring that into the institution
and work with
students and get them
to clarify their own voices.
You're teaching them how to
use a medium and then also, how
to speak through that medium.
So it's an interesting thing.
I think that helps
to pay it back.
I think I'm really happy to
also work at the community level
with places like Plaza
de la Raza, where
I get to work with youth and
those young kids that just love
working with art.
It's not even always
about the end product.
It's about the process of
working and having fun.
SANDRA CORNEJO: It's
the experience, yeah.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Those
experiences coming together
are what makes it a lot of fun.
So yeah.
SPEAKER: Of course.
Anything over there?
I have more questions.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yeah.
I think it's
important to mentor.
I've taught several places
throughout the 30 years
that I've been creating art.
I worked for Plaza
de la Raza teaching
and for Para Los Ninos for
inner city arts for 14 years.
And it was amazing to
work with the youth
and just to teach them
art but to also teach them
acceptance of who they are.
Right now, I work
with [INAUDIBLE]
teaching senior citizens
watercolor and ceramics.
SPEAKER: Hence, your AARP?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yes.
And they're absolutely lovely.
SPEAKER: That's nice.
And so you were here recently.
You're saying three
years ago, right?
SANDRA CORNEJO: Yeah.
SPEAKER: So they've
embraced you.
And now, is it too
early to give back?
What are you thinking about in
terms of the next generation?
SANDRA CORNEJO: Oh, man.
I'm excited to be working
with Plaza de La Raza.
I noticed that while I was
working for Margaret Garcia--
and I also worked for Frank
Romero, another artist
in the community--
I would assist them within their
classes at Plaza de la Raza.
And I realized that
there was really
nothing being offered for
the next generation that's
trying to move
forward and kind of
like hone in on their skills,
what they're really trying
to say and express,
and just like start
developing their own style,
their own voice through art.
So I proposed a portfolio
preparation course at Plaza.
And we're entering the
fourth semester now.
So I'm pretty excited about it.
We have many beautiful,
very talented artists.
And just giving them a space
to really think about the work
that they're making and have
them develop their style,
that was something that
was very important for me
as a kid in high school,
like having that teacher that
will just kind of will
give you the space and room
to do what you need to do.
And you know, just like
beginning dialogue,
having conversations
about your work.
There's more to it than just
a beautiful image, you know?
SPEAKER: Of course.
SANDRA CORNEJO: I already feel
like I'm giving into that.
I'm feeding it.
And it's feeding me as well.
It's definitely like a
reciprocal relationship.
SPEAKER: That's nice.
Love it.
I mean, as an artist.
I mean, your surroundings
shape you and influence
you and the people you meet and
all the travels that you do.
I mean, you've moved around.
You've traveled.
You've even done work in Assisi.
You've had a ton of things
also in the community.
There's a lot that goes on.
In my mind, can you think
of an anecdote, or a story,
or like one example that truly
shows when a piece of art
really made an impact?
Is there like the one?
Or is it like, no, all
the time, or everything?
I don't know.
Tell me, when and why?
What made that impact?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I got a story.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Yeah,
you got a story?
SPEAKER: I love it.
ROSALIE LOPEZ:
I've had this idea.
I make a lot of altars
and a lot of offerings.
So I've had this
idea for a long time.
And I was happy to
be able to do it.
Finally, like I think
three years into having it,
it was in my sketchbook.
I finally get to do it.
And got grant money to do it.
But I've always wanted to do
this pop-up altar installation
dedicated to my mom.
My mom, when she passed away,
we inherited all of her plants.
And so my sister and I started
taking care of her plants
and learning how to have
this green thumb because we
wanted to preserve her
through these plants.
And so I've been sprouting them.
And my sister and I
were living together,
and then we were
going to part ways.
She was going to get
a job somewhere else.
And the thought of not having
her plants was like, oh,
don't worry.
I'm going to clone them.
We can each have-- so
I cloned all the plants
and I started
getting into cloning.
I wanted to make a pop-up altar
where people shared stories
of their mothers with me.
And in exchange, I would give
them a sprouting plant from one
of my mom's plants.
So I wanted to gather and
archive all these stories
and post them up on social
media and on my website
so that people can listen
to these great stories
that they told and they shared
about women in their lives.
So this past Mother's Day,
the day before Mother's Day,
I was able to set up a little
pop-up on the LA river bed.
And I got a chance to do
it, sit at this huge altar
of beautiful, green
plants and just
seeing them sort of
perky and happy there--
the plants, that is.
I was like, this
is for you, Mom.
And then also,
hearing everyone's
stories of how
women in their lives
brought so much strength
and the amazing things
that people remembered.
And also, their connection to
this living thing-- a plant.
What that meant to
a lot of people.
And those stories that I
heard, it was like a constant--
I felt like that was giving
back because those memories stay
with people for the
rest of the day.
SPEAKER: Of course.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: They
remember that memory
about grandma or about auntie,
and it stays with them.
And I thought, man, I
almost forgot about that.
And it was because of
that moment, that event,
that they got to remember.
And that's what was
really important for me.
I felt like that
was my anecdote.
SPEAKER: That was beautiful.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Wow.
Are you going to do it again?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Oh, I'd love to.
I've always wanted to do
this, like in a flea market
or swap meet, and have a
different sort of crowd
and then grow that
archive and just
continue adding stories
and adding stories to it.
SPEAKER: Now you
can add all of us.
We can join you.
Sandra, you had a story as well.
SANDRA CORNEJO:
Oh, you could tell?
SPEAKER: Yes.
SANDRA CORNEJO: I got one.
So when I recently
moved here-- this
is why I think it's just
like when I moved here,
all the stars were
just like telling me,
like you're at the right
place at the right time.
When I had just moved here, I
remember I was in Home Depot,
and I was like walking around.
I was like, well, I need
a plant for my new home,
like, looking around.
And then I get an
unknown phone call.
And when I pick up,
Maria [INAUDIBLE]
is on the other line, at
the other end of the line.
And I'm not sure if you
guys are familiar with her,
but she was a very prominent
social justice figure
here in Los Angeles,
had survived
through many, many
things in El Salvador
and resettled in the United
States during the '80s.
So since the '80s,
she's been organizing
with so many different groups.
She heard about the
type of work that I
was doing, which is all based
on historical collective memory,
like stories from the
Salvadoran Civil War.
And she said to me like,
I'd love to meet you.
And you know, I'd
love to talk to you.
I'd love to have you paint
me, like have a sitting.
SPEAKER: Wow.
SANDRA CORNEJO: So we talked
about getting that together.
And I worked with
her for about a year.
And walked away
from the experience
with two really
beautiful paintings.
But throughout that
time span, like
she shared her stories with me.
We would go out for pupusas.
It's just a lot of
beautiful experiences.
But she also sat me down
to watch a documentary that
was done for her.
So we sat in a room,
held hands sometimes
because it was just like-- the
story was just really intense.
But she explained to me, maybe
midway of having spent time
with her, that she had cancer.
It had come back.
And she had a certain
amount of time to live.
So just having the
opportunity to sit with her
and paint her and
share her story
and exhibit it in
different spaces
brought so many people
together from different parts
of her life that would recognize
that person in the painting.
I walked up to one person,
a patron of mine actually,
and she was crying when she
was seeing the painting.
And she shared with me-- like
once Maria had already passed,
she had shared the stories
that they shared together, like
through [INAUDIBLE].
And so I feel like it was just
a very organic and natural thing
that just happened.
And I feel fortunate to have
been able to document that
and to just produce something
that keeps her memory living.
SPEAKER: That's pretty magical.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Yeah.
I'd love to show you
guys the images now.
But her story was
definitely about survival.
There's a beauty to it.
But there was also a
lot of darkness to it.
So I think yeah, it
was just very powerful.
SPEAKER: Thank you for sharing.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Of course.
Thank you.
SPEAKER: Yolanda.
In all your experience,
tell me one, maybe?
I don't know.
Can you?
Can you reduce it?
I don't know.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yeah,
I could reduce it.
I think one that is very recent.
I was recently
commissioned by [INAUDIBLE]
to create a sculpture for
one of their facilities.
And I have been creating
ceramics for about 20 years.
And there are these women that I
make that are called [SPANISH]..
And they have these [SPANISH].
And they're very colorful
and very strong women.
So they asked me to
create this piece, which
was going to end up being about
six feet tall in ceramics.
So I started to create it.
We had the heads that are
large orbs, about this big.
We created the heads,
the torso, and the skirt.
And it's during a
time where I was
going through a very difficult
transition in my life.
So we created the skirt,
which is about this tall.
And it's going into
the kiln and it breaks.
And it was very symbolic of
what I was going through.
We created another one.
It went into the kiln.
When it came out,
it was cracked.
Then we created a third.
And when it came out--
and in some form, I was in
a stronger place and kind
of more comfortable where
I was and wasn't struggling
so much with the transition.
She came out fine.
SPEAKER: How long was that
process between the first one--
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
It's been six months.
It was six months.
And then also, creating the
orbs and the heads for me
was very organic.
And feeling these orbs
and creating the portrait,
I felt it was like, this is what
it would be like to give birth,
this orb.
I felt it, and it was cool.
The smell of the clay was
just so beautiful and magical.
So I created her.
It took four men to install her
because she's about 600 pounds.
She was installed.
And so once she was
installed and I turned around
and I looked at her, I
cried because I thought,
we have both completed
this process together.
And that's what that
piece was for me.
It was building myself
up again to continue
what I had to continue.
SPEAKER: Beautiful.
Very symbolic.
Wow.
So is there anything that--
I know, transitioning
from that is like--
we cry.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: It's
an artist, artist life.
SPEAKER: Then we get back up.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Welcome
to the artist life.
SPEAKER: So in this roller
coaster of emotions,
is there anything you regret?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: None.
SPEAKER: Nothing?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Not one.
SPEAKER: Is there some
type of artwork or genre
that you would never do?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Oh, wow.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Can't
say that, though.
SPEAKER: I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm asking.
SANDRA CORNEJO: You
can't say never.
We have so much to--
SPEAKER: Or that you
wouldn't want to.
Or that you're
like, have fear of.
Is there like a thing that
you're like, I try to avoid it?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ:
I think if there's
different mediums, because
people will come to you.
I was sent to Japan
to do printmaking.
And I had done some printmaking
at Self Help Graphics, but not
that much.
But what do you do is
you essentially interpret
it, that style, that
medium, in your process.
SPEAKER: OK.
So you make it your own?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: And then therefore,
it's accepting to you?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Yes.
SPEAKER: But is there
anything else that you
were like, I don't know?
I don't want to go there.
It's not something
that's my style.
I don't want to--
maybe?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It's an
interesting question.
When I think about
moments in my life
where I wondered if I had
gone this way versus that way,
I definitely thought about--
there was a time in my life
when I had just graduated
and I got my BFA
degree and I was going
to be going into grad school.
And there was a
time in between then
when I lost my
brother unexpectedly
at a very young age.
SPEAKER: Sorry.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
He died of an overdose.
And I was like
really distraught.
And my family was out of
state, and I was in California.
I stayed here in California.
And they had moved away.
And I really felt like I
wanted to be with them.
And it was so difficult. But
here I am in a part of my life
where I'm supposed to decide
where out of state I'm
going to school.
And it was a horrible
feeling that should
have been like much different.
And so my heart wanted to go to
New Mexico where my family was.
And I had gotten an opportunity
to go to grad school
on a Fulbright
Scholarship in Indiana
University and the thought
of going across the country,
leaving Los Angeles
and going to a place
where you really are different.
SPEAKER: Sure.
Yeah.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It
was heart-wrenching.
It was my mom's advice
that sort of pushed me
into continuing to
go into that route.
Because it was like, that's what
he would have wanted you to do.
But it wasn't what
I wanted to do.
I wanted to go and be with them.
So I wondered what my life
would be like if I had continued
and lived out--
I don't know, maybe
applied to school out there
and decided to go a
different route with my life.
But while I was in
Indiana, I totally
got immersed in
using altars as a way
to remember to heal and to
learn to have my own voice.
And living in that
place where there's not
as much social diversity
as we have in Los Angeles,
it really forced me to
have to talk about my work
to people who didn't
understand it.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Which is good.
SPEAKER: Of course.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It was great.
Yeah, that experience
was very difficult.
But also, I think that--
yeah.
It just was a point in
my life where I thought,
I wonder how I
would have ended up
if I had gone somewhere
else versus here.
SPEAKER: Of course.
Wow.
Yeah.
Speechless a bit?
Very strong women.
Wow.
I love all these stories.
And thank you.
They're very personal.
We're very thankful that
you're sharing that with us.
I feel like I'm part of--
like I'm in your homes
and you're like--
I need to give you some
[SPANISH] or [SPANISH]..
SANDRA CORNEJO:
Where's the [SPANISH]??
SPEAKER: I'm like, this
is really emotional.
[INAUDIBLE] getting in touch
with these beautiful stories.
Thank you.
Wow.
OK.
So I want to touch a little
bit more on the whole aspect
that you were just
touching on of you
had to explain your art to
people who really didn't get it
or didn't understand it.
How was that process?
Have you had that
experience, too?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I'm
going to speak as--
acknowledging the fact that I'm
very young in this environment.
But it made me realize how much
more I had to study and learn
the artists who were working
in this form before me.
And understand
their conversations
and where it was coming from
because it helped me build up
my strength to even be able
to communicate these things.
I want to talk about
a person's life
and celebrate it without
feeling the drabness of death
and leaving this life.
And I want to celebrate
them and the lessons
that they taught me.
And how do I do that?
And Dia de los Muertos
and altars and ofrendras
gave me that venue to be
able to talk about it.
So I studied.
I researched.
I definitely wanted
to investigate
a lot of Chicanas who were
using altars as another way.
Not just to commemorate
their [INAUDIBLE],,
but as a way to talk about
the social dynamics of where
they're coming from.
And how they can communicate
that in a public atmosphere.
It doesn't have to be
in a whitewall gallery.
It can be in a public space.
So growing up in LA, and having
places like Self Help Graphics
that are pioneering contemporary
Dia de los Muertos, de los
Muertos, the Chicanoized
version of Dia de los Muertos,
it was like setting
the pathway for me
to discuss all of
these things and to be
who I wanted to be and
talk about my family
and also my situation and relate
it to everyone else around me.
And even though I was
all the way in Indiana,
I had the access to resources
to do this homework,
to look at books and
to read and research.
So when I came back home, I
felt like a lot more empowered
to understand it when
you kind of take it
for granted a little
bit growing up in it.
SPEAKER: Sure.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
SPEAKER: That's great.
And you empowered a
ton of other people
and now they're more educated.
You empowered everyone here.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
It's more than just like
[SPANISH] and makeup.
And you know, let's
not forget this--
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
pretty picture.
Exactly.
Of course.
Thank you.
Sandra, you were
going to say anything?
No?
Maybe?
But I do have a question.
Tell me.
So we were discussing this
voice that you have as artists.
How has social media, or
digital, or technology
helped your careers?
Or not?
Maybe not.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Well,
I mean, it helps
in the sense of
having you connected
with so many of your
peers and your colleagues.
And I mean, being
able to research.
And especially the way that
I gather source material.
I very much needed the
internet and social media
to be able to do that.
But in particular, maybe.
I don't know.
Maybe not.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
I'm very intrigued by
the fact that art is now
accessible to all.
So the minute you
do something, it
is seen by millions and
millions of eyeballs
all over the world instantly.
And so when you're making this
now, because it's different.
Maybe even 30 years ago, right?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER: I mean, when you're
creating something now--
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I
want to hear hers.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I was
excited about beepers.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Page me.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: How can
I make love with a beeper?
Turn it around.
It's not 8-3-8-3.
It's love.
SPEAKER: It's 1-4-3, 1-4-3.
I was there, too.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I remember
the phones with the long cords.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: So Yolanda, I have
a question for you then.
So in the 30-year
span, you've gone
from you didn't have
digital, really,
to now having people
see your artwork,
if they wanted to,
around the world.
Does it change now
your perspective when
you're painting in the
sense that before, people
would go and--
wherever you had the
exhibition, people would see it.
It was that [INAUDIBLE] people.
Maybe you toured.
Whatever it is, those are
the people who saw it, right?
Who seeked it out.
But now anybody can
see it and share it.
Does that change
how you paint now
and the voice or the
message you want to give?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I think
it changes a lot of things
except for the way I paint.
Because the painting
process and my relationship
with the creative process
is very pure to me.
It's very sacred.
And so that is very strong one
of the strongest relationships
I have.
But it's very exciting
to me to share.
And what I like to
do is put a piece--
when I first start the
sketch, the rough, when
it's almost done, and
then when it's completed.
So people can kind
of see the process
of what's happening
of creation, so be it.
People put their kid's pictures
every month on Facebook.
And I put my paintings
Those are my babies.
That's it.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I think that's
what's exciting about it,
is like we get to see the
studio practice unfurled
in front of us on
Instagram and Facebook.
And it's also hard to get used
to it, to opening people up
to that process.
SANDRA CORNEJO: How much
do you want to show?
How much is exposed?
Like you want to keep some of
those things private, right?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: It's whatever
you're comfortable with.
It's whatever you're
comfortable really sharing.
Because it's out there.
And once it's out
there, it's out there.
But it is amazing.
And I've utilized it
to the fullest where
you send out your message.
And you send out your images.
And then, you
represent messages that
need to be represented as well.
But I think it's a fascinating
process, the internet.
It's just fascinating to me.
And I'm such a gadget person.
I love that.
So anything I can get my little
hands on and expose people
to what's going on, or my
world, my little utopian,
strange world, it's there.
SPEAKER: That's great.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: It's exciting.
I feel like we're
living in a world
where there's all kinds of
new technology happening
all the time.
And as artists, we
get to figure out how
to interpret that and use that.
I'm a printmaker.
And it's one of those
classic dying forms
that people don't
like to use anymore
because it's very cumbersome.
But there's always
this conversation
on how we're pulling
from new technology
to influence our work.
So how do we keep it
relevant in this age
of like constant
technology upgrades?
I'd like to see how it impacts
the conversation I want to have
or the way I envision
a piece happening.
Some of the ways that I've used
it is I'm a graphic designer.
So a lot of the work also
starts off on the computer
and using digital programs or
digitizing the work somehow.
And then, seeing how
the work can transmute.
I've had a chance to use CNC
router machines to create
custom furniture pieces that are
reminiscent of my papel picado
patterns.
And that was an
amazing experience
or like laser-cutting
machines that
take papel picado [INAUDIBLE]
whole other world.
What happens when the
machine cuts it out?
And you have these little burned
edges and how those things
start to impact the message.
And I'd be excited to be able
to play with it even more.
I think what becomes a biggest
deterrent is accessibility.
It's expensive.
It's hard to get access to.
Especially once you're outside
and you don't have access
to a university or
anything like that,
how do you use this
equipment in your work?
Yeah, I'd be excited to try
to learn to use it more.
And it provides
another way for you
to have that communication
so any other way that I
can try to use technology.
I've used it for
sharing the stories
that I'm collecting to
have this online archive
or an online altar.
So I try to use it
as much as possible,
but I think that there's
also some deterrence because
of the accessibility of it, too.
SPEAKER: Of course.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
SPEAKER: They're big machines
you're talking about, too.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
I'm interested in how
they collide, though.
How do you think the old
school and the classic
with like the new technology?
SPEAKER: And there's the
3D printers now, too.
ROSALIE LOPEZ:
Yeah, 3D printing.
I'd love to mess around
with that kind of machinery.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Nice.
Well, so now I'm going to open
it up to the audience as well.
If you have any
questions at all, please,
this is your time to--
SANDRA CORNEJO: There's
the microphone box.
SPEAKER: See?
The one we were talking about.
The one you can throw around.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: A Google Cube.
SPEAKER: Anybody have questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
[INAUDIBLE]
Hi, everyone.
My name is Eric.
So first of all, thank you
guys for spending an afternoon
with us.
I thought this was really
interesting and really awesome.
And I'm really happy
that you guys came by.
So now, my question
is, a few months ago,
there was like a case in Canada,
where a writer was criticized
for saying that other writers
and artists should take
and write from the point of
view of different ethnicities,
cultures, genders,
and background.
And so I was kind of curious
to hear what you guys thought,
if you would encourage others to
sort of take the point of view
of people that come from
different backgrounds
that they do?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I think
that's a big responsibility.
SPEAKER: It is, yeah.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I
only have my own view.
And I can't expect everybody
to respect or accept
my point of view on a whole
of a culture, an ethnicity.
I don't think that's right.
SANDRA CORNEJO: I think
any artist out there
that's making work--
I mean, their true
aspiration should
be to convey a truly honest
perspective of their own.
So I feel like being
able to share that.
I mean, that's how
other people are
able to learn about it, right?
But to put yourself
in a different place?
It gets tricky.
SPEAKER: Of course.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: You
don't want to be
put in a position where you're
the spokesperson for everyone.
And that just doesn't seem fair.
It's important to be
inclusive, to be aware.
But to be put in
the position of I'm
the spokesperson for
Latinas, and I would never
want that responsibility.
There's too many voices
out there to be heard.
So yeah, that's a
pretty tough criticism.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: It's also
a lot of hard work.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Good question.
Yeah.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Definitely.
And I completely agree.
Like I mean, there's the variety
of opinions about it, I guess.
And like on one side,
you should say like, oh,
by encouraging people to
talk about cultures that
are different than
their own, you
encourage them to
find commonalities,
to find ways to empathize.
And then from the other point
of view, kind of like you said,
it's, well, there
are many people that
could talk about this
particular experience,
so why is somebody that may
not have as much experience
or knowledge in that background
take it upon themselves
to talk about it?
So I was kind of curious to
hear what you guys thought.
So thank you.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Thank
you for the question.
AUDIENCE: So cool.
Ladies, thank you so
much for being here.
And I want to take it to
the business perspective.
Women traditionally make
$0.72 of the dollar of males.
Black women make $0.62
and Latinas even less.
So I'm wondering, in terms
of your male counterparts
as artists when you're
comparing art to art, do
you find yourself having to--
or not making as much as
men do in the industry?
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Do we choose
to price it less than,
is that what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: No.
Are people wanting you to
charge less because you're
women or Latinas?
SPEAKER: That's interesting.
SANDRA CORNEJO: I've
seen that on both ends
of the different artists
I've worked with since being
in Los Angeles--
the more recognized, like male
figure, and a woman that's
been struggling and
really putting in the work
since she began,
like decades ago.
And just realizing
that there's that--
like women tend to
under-price their work.
I don't know.
It's difficult.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I
think as a woman artist,
it's important not to
under-price my work,
to value my work for the years
that I've been creating art.
And it's been 30 long years.
And I think it's a huge
responsibility for the artists,
the young artists,
who are following
me to open the door for them
not only through my art,
but through my business sense.
So you educate people to pay if
they want a piece of your art.
They want a piece of your soul.
They're paying for it properly.
SANDRA CORNEJO: And if they
don't buy it at that price,
then they don't deserve it.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: If they
don't buy at that price,
somebody else will.
And I have little pieces.
You can get a little
piece about this big.
You can take home.
That will be fine.
SPEAKER: Nice.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Yeah, you
just got to know your worth
and stick to it.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: And it's
hard because a lot of artists
are not businesspeople.
I think it's
difficult to separate
because you're emotionally
involved to this piece of art.
But then what you do
is you find somebody
who you trust to represent your
art and to market it that way.
SPEAKER: Yeah.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
I struggle with that a
lot as well because I
worry about accessibility.
And I think that when
those things are true,
pricing and the
time and what you've
invested, where your career
is at, all of those things
that factor into pricing.
And then, some of the
things I worry about
is like, who can buy that?
Who is going to be
able to buy that?
Who am I making it for?
And even though I
know it's not going
to make me very much
money, I want my artwork
to be accessible.
I don't want it to be
unreachable, unattainable for
people to be able to purchase.
So I need to hire
a businessperson.
[LAUGHS] I feel like I
want a little of both.
I think that creating
tiers of work
that you can sell
for different prices
helps to make things
that are accessible.
And you have bigger ideas.
A lot of my work is
installation artwork, too.
I don't really intend on--
it's a temporary installation.
And it exists for
that point in time.
So sales, a lot of times,
aren't really the driving force.
It's more like, how can
I complete this idea?
I just moved back to Los
Angeles after living away
for six years.
And this past year
that I've been back,
I've really been
forced to think--
the people and the friends
that I've met have really made
me think a lot about pricing.
And I was sort of living in, I
feel like, my own little dream
world of I just want
to do the idea, man.
I'm just trying to get
this idea out there.
The cash wasn't even about it.
And that's kind of
the struggling part,
so that's why I teach.
That's one of the
reasons why I teach.
SPEAKER: Of course.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Got
to have that side job.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: So I
can have that freeness
to be able to create what
I want to create and not
be driven by the price.
But it's a struggling
game of back and forth.
And you know, Yolanda's
very established
and has a lot of years.
And I hope one day to
kind of get to a level
where I can be a lot more
demanding with it, too.
But I also think there's
a line, too, about where
you want to be open and
have people find you and get
to know you and create that
relationship through being
a little more accessible.
Yeah, it's difficult.
It's very difficult.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I think
as far as accessibility,
if somebody comes
into the studio
and they really want a piece,
instead of lowering the price,
if it's a small
piece or something,
I'll just give it to them.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I
got payment plans.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: No.
I literally just say--
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Layaway.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I
just say, take it.
If you want it, take it.
I have a watercolor series
that's really, really
reasonable for my work.
But some of the paintings now--
when I was your guys age, I
would paint five, six, seven,
10 paintings in a week.
Now--
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Pump it out.
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: That's
why I have shoulder pain.
But now, it's once a month.
It's It slows down.
But that's just where I'm at.
That's just what 30 years
of the process has taken me.
And I have to be
accepting of that.
I'm not 25 anymore.
But anytime you want to come
over and talk, we'll talk.
I'm there.
I'm open to that.
SPEAKER: Any other questions?
So I'm going to end with
one last one since--
any other questions?
Back to the next
generation, I love--
there's a ton of people who
not only are digital natives.
They don't know anything
else but the online world
but also are really
intrigued or really want
to explore art as part
of who they are, maybe
as their career.
What advice can you give
them, for this next generation
of artists?
I always believe that you
can't just have technology.
You can't just have art.
I think the combination
works really nicely now,
especially now with STEAM,
where you can do both.
What advice can you give the
next generation of people
or kids who want to pursue art?
YOLANDA GONZALEZ: I think
just the old classic,
follow your dream.
But now, the dream is very large
and vast with the internet.
And I think it's
amazing for them
to have that accessibility
to the internet.
But I also think that the
classic way of learning art
is very important.
So I think if there
is a way to have
the classic way of learning
art, which is pencil, charcoal,
still life and then transfer
that into the internet,
and combine it, and incorporate
it, and collaborate with it.
I think that's the fascinating
part of the new art we're going
to be seeing in the future.
SPEAKER: Nice.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Know
where you come from.
Continue to be curious,
explore, and just
continue to ask questions,
like within your own work.
Definitely.
SPEAKER: Nice.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: I don't know.
I have thought about this
question a few different ways.
There's a lot of artists now who
solely exist on social media,
like their main venues
are on social media.
And they have a really hard
time doing the classic stuff.
[INAUDIBLE]
Like, I already got
this many followers
and they're all--
you know what I mean?
It's a different
way of thinking.
But I think that's
the challenge of how
the classic and traditional
still engage that newer age,
because they found
ways to bypass
a lot of the traditional stuff.
Why do I need to learn how
to draw the figure if I'm
doing specific performances
in random spots in LA
and I'm getting commissions?
And they're getting
paid for doing it.
So it's the challenge
that I think
that the institution
hasn't quite yet led up
to learning how to teach
those students how to keep up
with it all, because they're
struggling with keeping up
with that new technology.
I think, too, that
I remember being
a student and the mode of
thinking being like, concept,
concept, concept.
And those things
are really amazing.
If you're wanting
to be an artist,
there's different
types of artists.
Some people just paint
in their basements
and never expose
it to the public.
It's about that moment
that they're creating.
And it's not really about
sharing it with everybody.
Some other people
have the yearning
to want to share it
out in the public.
And it's about that
communication, the way
that people perceive
it in a public space.
And that's what
drives that force.
So I don't know that I would
have one piece of advice
for artists.
It would be like, what's
your main goal for this?
Yeah, it's like STEM is
huge right now in schools.
And you hear-- like I'm
looking for jobs all the time
and they want to know how
you can incorporate STEM
into your curriculum.
And I think that
acceleratingly, it's
more important because the
schools have stripped away
like a lot of those arts and
creatives out of the school,
but they want to
bring it on again
as an educational component
to teach them science,
to teach them all
these other things.
But where can art
exist just for art?
When you're a kid, you think
you're thinking about concept?
No.
You're remembering
that fun part of why
you want to make art,
of what it is to create.
And it's important
not to lose that.
We're so strained, I think,
to have this a greater,
bigger social message.
And those things
are very important,
but there should also still
live a space where you can just
be free to create just because.
And you may not
know why, but you
need to have that
happen at the same time
that other people are more
driven by that message.
So to have both
existing simultaneously,
I think and not
knock people down
for having a different
way of thinking about it
or working with it.
SPEAKER: That's great.
I agree completely.
I think there's
a space for both.
And also, separately.
ROSALIE LOPEZ: Yeah.
SPEAKER: And together.
Why not, right?
Again, thank you so, so much.
You've been wonderful.
Thank you for sharing such
beautiful, personal stories,
for allowing us to have and
share your beautiful work
right here in our halls, and
just for being here today.
SANDRA CORNEJO: Thank you.
SPEAKER: Thank you, ladies.
[APPLAUSE]